Attackers can also use analysis
of his attacks to disrupt
the network intrusion detection process.
In addition to intrusion
detection systems,
there's also intrusion
prevention systems.
Instead of simply sending
alerts like and IDS.
And IDS would try to block the attack
when it detects malicious activities.
For example,
it can block network traffic that
involves malicious activities.
Similar to an IDS, an IPS can
be deployed at the end host and
the network perimeter or
a combination of different locations.
An IPS also uses the similar
detection algorithms of an IDS.
For example,
it can use anomaly detection algorithm
to detect abnormal behavior.
And stop such abnormal behavior.
And this is the main difference
between an IPS and a firewall.
A firewall typically only use simple
signatures of attacks to stop traffic.
Whereas, an IPS can use very
sophisticated detection algorithms.